it took bitcoin 12 years to become a
trillion dollar network
and there's nothing else bitcoin is
worthless artificial gold
i must say i bought some and it's my
best investment
so i'm not uh bullish on bitcoin
and bitcoin is the best money currently
available because it's decentralized it
cannot be stopped
the main motivation is uh for the price
to go up they don't use it they don't
transact in it
they just huddle it and and they're
hoping they get rich
and what's your response to that people
not using bitcoin
a few months ago i asked for your
thoughts on bitcoin
the responses i received were exactly as
i was expecting
most didn't understand it some of you
labelled it a scam
and others praised it extensively saying
it's going to be one of the biggest
things in the future
or that it's going to make us question
what exactly money and currency
really is you see i avoided looking into
bitcoin for as long as i could
but there's only so many social media
profiles with laser eyes in them that
you can bear before you start to ask
what exactly is going on here and the
more i tried to answer that question the
more intrigued i was by
bitcoin and the ongoing saga it's become
take
for example the fact that it's creator
an individual or a group of individuals
under the pseudonym satoshi nakamoto
remains anonymous and unidentified to
this day
and is said to own one million bitcoins
which at the time of making this video
makes nakamoto worth over 62 billion
dollars
theoretically should the price of a
single bitcoin rise to 177 000
nakamoto would be the richest person in
the world were they to sell their coins
but nakamoto is only one part of what
makes this ongoing saga so
fascinating truth is it's a wild world
out there and i think it's time that you
and i finally take a step into the realm
of crypto and begin to make sense of it
all
[Music]
bitcoin is a story it's a story about
the very thing that influences
our actions today the piece of paper
that we call money or the numbers you
see on a screen
in your bank account but if you rewind
time far enough
you'll find that our ancestors purchased
goods using a method we wouldn't
recognize
today payment first began with barter
a system which involved trading goods
for other goods
a few fish for a loaf of bread a dozen
eggs for a bunch of
lettuce and so on but this system had a
problem it relied on us
wanting what the other person had it
relied on a coincidence of
wants so our ancestors realized that we
needed a medium of exchange
to represent the value of the items they
wanted to buy
such as cattle shells and eventually
coins made of precious metals
then thousands of years later countries
started using
paper money that was backed by gold in
other words the dollar would be backed
by a certain amount of gold and you
could
theoretically exchange those dollars for
physical gold that a country held in its
reserves
this system was known as the gold
standard
in 1971 however the us officially left
the gold standard along with many other
countries
this meant that the dollar was no longer
backed up by gold the dollar was simply
backed up on the basis that the
government decreed that it had
value and we all agreed that it does
doing this
allowed governments and central banks to
have more control over our money supply
making it easier to use monetary policy
to respond to times of financial crisis
this type of money the money that we use
today which is no longer backed up by
gold
but rather our faith in government is
known as fiat money now there exists
both arguments
for and against fiat money but the
important thing to realize here is that
this system
relies on trust in government but what
if you don't
have that trust who do you turn to then
emerging in the late 1980s the
cypherpunks were part of a movement that
was against
centralized authorities like governments
being able to spy on people or have
access to their information
they advocated for what is known as
cryptography ways in which we're able to
secure communication in the presence of
third parties
typically through the use of encryption
with their libertarian views
the cypherpunks saw a clear
contradiction between their values and
the current financial system when they
looked at banks
or central banks they saw centralized
institutions with the power to print as
much money as they wanted on their terms
we the people trust our banking
institutions to be a safe place to put
our money that they won't mismanage it
and
ultimately collapse cypherpunks did not
lehman brothers is going bankrupt and
financial markets from asia to europe
are doing their utmost to prevent monday
from turning from dark
to black brought down by bad mortgage
investments lehman which has
25 000 employees will be liquidated the
american people
can remain confident in the soundness
and the resilience of our financial
system
major financial institutions have
teetered on the edge of collapse
and some have failed we are in the midst
of a serious
financial crisis in 2007 and 2008
a global financial crisis was unfolding
a crisis that had its roots in risky
lending from banks
so much so that it led to the collapse
of one of the united states biggest
banks at the time
lehman brothers it was perhaps no
coincidence then that under the shadow
of the 2008 financial crisis
a white paper titled bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system
began to circulate on a cryptography
mailing list a paper that was written by
someone under the pseudonym of satoshi
nakamoto this nine-page manifesto was a
blueprint for what nakamoto described as
a purely peer-to-peer version of
electronic cash which would allow
payments to be sent directly from one
party
to another without going through a
financial institution
nakamoto took the technological
innovations of former cypherpunks
and put them together into what we now
call blockchain technology
to put it simply nakamoto laid out a
framework
using mathematics computer science and
cryptography
to create a currency that could be used
for transactions without needing to
trust
a central authority trust was the
problem
bitcoin was set out to solve now let's
pause for a moment
here is where things can get a little
confusing whilst we've covered the
motivations behind bitcoin
now we must figure out what exactly is
it and how is it decentralized
understanding blockchain technology is
the key to understanding the fanaticism
around bitcoin that we see
today bitcoin is not a physical coin
it is in fact entirely virtual a digital
currency
think of bitcoin as simply transactions
on a ledger
for example let's say ben pays two
bitcoins to
jane and jane pays two bitcoins to carl
these transactions are recorded on a
ledger and so on and so forth for every
transaction that comes after
banks work in a similar way recording
the transactions made through a bank
account each and every day
using their own system verifying that
the transactions made are in fact valid
in other words a bank can make sure that
somebody with only a hundred dollars in
their account cannot spend any more than
that bitcoin
however is intended to be decentralized
so how could it possibly
verify that the transactions made on its
ledger are legitimate
that ben even has two bitcoins to send
to jain in the first place
this is where we introduced the concept
of a peer-to-peer or distributed ledger
system that nakamoto outlined in his
white paper
instead of a central authority owning
the ledger that records all bitcoin
transactions
the ledger is instead distributed
amongst all the other computers
or nodes in the bitcoin network a
network that anyone with a computer can
join simply by downloading the bitcoin
software
now each time a transaction is made on
the ledger every computer on the network
will attempt to verify
whether this transaction is legitimate
by solving complex algorithms when a
consensus is reached on the network and
the transaction is valid it will be
permanently stored on the ledger if a
single node on the network attempts to
validate an incorrect transaction
all the other nodes on the network will
reject it and after a certain amount of
transactions are made on the ledger a
new ledger is created that contains a
type of code
otherwise called a hash that links back
to the previous ledger this is why we
call it a blockchain
each of these ledgers or blocks contain
a certain amount of transactions
that are then linked to the previous
block in the chain and no public
identities
are used when transacting on the bitcoin
blockchain instead
individuals have both a public and a
private key which appear as a string of
random numbers and letters
a private key is used to create a
digital signature
and a public key is used to verify the
signature without revealing the private
key
this process of validating transactions
on the block is known as mining
miners receive a reward of a few
bitcoins for every block they
successfully mine
incentivizing them to continue adding to
the blockchain if someone attempts to
hack or invalidate a previous block on
the blockchain they would end up
invalidating every single block that
comes after it which would be easy to
detect
and reject by the network the bitcoin
blockchain allows you to see
every single transaction that has ever
been made since the very first block
without being able to alter or change
the records in other words
it's a decentralized form of currency
that doesn't rely
on trust between parties for
transactions to occur you can still find
the very first block on the bitcoin
blockchain today
mined by the mysterious satoshi nakamoto
in 2009
showing that nakamoto was given a total
of 50 bitcoins as a reward for mining
the first block
this block is commonly referred to as
the genesis block
nakamoto had also set the supply limit
for bitcoins as 21 million within the
software code itself
as of today there are only two million
bitcoins left
to mine now admittedly all of this can
seem very confusing at the start
and it's very difficult to explain all
of this inside of one video like we're
trying to do now there are however many
other resources that you can use to
learn about bitcoin and blockchain
technology one of which
is skillshare who are kindly sponsoring
this video if you haven't heard of them
already skillshare is an online
community with amazing classes
at the moment skillshare has a
demystifying cryptocurrency
understanding bitcoin and beyond class
by milton demiros
who does a brilliant job of explaining
some of the jargon that you'll commonly
hear in the cryptocurrency space
and breaking down how bitcoin technology
works even better
skillshare is at the price of about 10 a
month for an annual subscription which
is the same price as
two coffees a month and the first 1000
people to click the link in the
description of this video will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
i've been using skillshare myself for a
long while and i still use it to this
day to help me with things like video
editing
one class i recently took was on
animating kinetic typography on after
effects
but there are a ton of other classes on
skillshare ranging from
creative writing web design illustration
and all sorts of other things
so remember to click the link in the
description below and be one of the
first
1 000 people to claim your free trial of
the premium membership
today
but one question still remains how did
bitcoin
reach the price it's at today could
digital currency with albeit brilliant
technology
truly be worth more than 60 thousand
dollars
price is a matter of demand so how did
the demand
ever reach this point in the first place
in early 2009
after releasing their infamous white
paper nakamoto
mined the genesis block setting into
motion a series of events that would
change its future forever
the early adopters of bitcoin included
those from the cypherpunk movement
and others who mined bitcoin just as a
hobby
until 2010 bitcoin was worth practically
nothing yet that would soon change
that year during the month of may a man
named lazlo honyats
created a post on a bitcoin discussion
forum offering to pay 10 000 bitcoins
for two large pizzas
two days later laszlo reported that he
had successfully traded his bitcoin for
25 dollars worth of pizza this was the
very first recorded transaction in which
bitcoin was used to purchase a tangible
item and just like that the digital
currency
took its first big step in becoming
recognized as having value
the 22nd of may was officially dubbed
bitcoin pizza day
by the end of 2010 bitcoin had gone from
being worth nothing
to 39 cents and the very first bitcoin
exchange
mount gox was set up making it easier
for people to trade their bitcoins with
regular currencies
in 2011 bitcoin reached a price of one
dollar
and suddenly we began seeing the
emergence of other cryptocurrencies
using the very same blockchain
technology that bitcoin uses
these alternative cryptocurrencies
otherwise known as altcoins
aim to solve their own problems by
making changes to the original bitcoin
whilst bitcoin's intentions are to be a
digital currency
a cryptocurrency like ethereum is
attempting to do something entirely
different using blockchain technology
both of which require their own research
and looking into there are currently
thousands of altcoins out there and some
of which are ponzi or pump and dumb
schemes that serve
no use purpose bitcoin did however
struggle in its early years from a poor
reputation and multiple scandals
its use of a private and a public key
system allowed for a level of anonymity
which made it perfect for criminals and
illegal use purposes
silk road was a notorious website on the
dark web which engaged in the buying and
selling of illegal substances with which
bitcoins were used for transactions
the website itself was a sophisticated
endeavor that proved tough to crack
it used the online currency bitcoins and
operated in the so-called
deep web because of this the association
of bitcoin with black markets like silk
road
put a stain on its reputation that can
still be felt today
another significant scandal during these
years was the collapse of mount gox
bitcoin's first and biggest exchange
which at one point
handled up to 70 percent of all bitcoin
transactions
heard of an online currency exchange
known as mount gox
his website had been one of the largest
online exchanges
for the digital cryptocurrency known as
bitcoins the site went offline tuesday
amid allegations of major theft
and carpals acknowledged today he can't
account for 850
000 bitcoins mount gox unexpectedly
shut down today owing hundreds of
millions of pounds
what was once one of the world's biggest
bitcoin exchanges mount gox has filed
for bankruptcy protection in japan
but even during bitcoin's worst days the
demand still remained
with the launch of companies like bitpay
which provided mobile transactions for
businesses
wanting to accept bitcoin the
speculation around the cryptocurrency
reached new heights in 2013 bitcoin
reached 1 000
at its peak before dropping into the
hundreds it was in 2017 however
when bitcoin faced its most unbelievable
year yet
in japan that very year a law was passed
that accepted bitcoin as the legal
payment method
the hype and speculation continue to
mount as headline after headline
reported bitcoin
reaching all-time highs it's during
these moments of a bubble where suddenly
everyone you ever knew is talking about
bitcoin
the market was getting greedy and
irrational there were companies simply
adding blockchain to their name and
seeing
their share prices surged 394
at the peak of it all in december of
2017
a single bitcoin was worth almost 20 000
but just as fast as the hype and
speculation had come
it had also burst
if you think the dow had a bad day
bitcoins was worse the price is now
having around seven
thousand dollars a jaw-dropping loss of
nearly 15 percent just check the members
yeah 15
over the course within days after
hitting its peak bitcoin began to tumble
back down in price
spurred on partly because of government
crackdowns as cryptocurrency exchanges
were banned in china
the fear of missing out swiftly became
the fear of losing money
and the price of cryptocurrencies
collapsed 80 since its peak
making the 2018 cryptocurrency crash
worse than the dot-com crash
i mean i bought bitcoin when it was
twenty thousand dollars
and i literally put three hundred
thousand dollars in there
that 300 was like literally my life
savings
you know by december of that year
bitcoin had fallen to just over 3
200 and yet despite the crash
bitcoin's worth remained in the
thousands and now
only three years after the 2018 crash
bitcoin is worth over 60 000
at the time of recording why
what separates a retail investor from an
institutional investor
for one it's money a lot of money
it's for that reason then that the
recent institutional
interest in bitcoin is what is fueling
the current insanity that we see today
this morning from paypal the company's
venmo app will now allow its 70 million
customers to buy hold and sell
cryptocurrency now the rollout begins
today and it's going to be available to
all customers in the next few weeks
elon musk does it again a shock
announcement and an immediate market
response
tesla has put one and a half billion
dollars into bitcoin
and musk will accept bitcoin as payment
and as the us federal reserve continues
printing money in order to boost the
economy under the current circumstances
the fear of rising inflation grows
stronger
and stronger you see the narrative
around bitcoin
has changed whereas in its initial white
paper bitcoin was intended to be a
currency
more and more investors are looking at
bitcoin as a store of value instead
we'll dive deeper into this pivot during
the next part of this series but it's
important to acknowledge that
institutional
interest in bitcoin was something it was
previously lacking
bitcoin ultimately has to rely on
people's belief in its ability to be a
currency
or as we now see it being used as a
store of value
and yet there are those who say that
bitcoin is not worth
its current price or those that think
its price is being manipulated
to a great extent the price of bitcoin
is totally manipulated by bunch of
people
by a bunch of ways i think the whole
damn development is disgusting
former paypal ceo bill harris called the
cryptocurrency quote
the greatest scam in history noting that
it is a pump and dump scheme
i could care less with bitcoin trades
for how it trades wiretrace who trades
it if you're stupid enough to buy you'll
pay the price for it one day
the next part of this series will be
coming shortly as we take a dive into
the heated
debate and speculation around bitcoin
today the link for that will be in the
description when it's out but i would
absolutely recommend you learn about
bitcoin and blockchain technology
yourself especially if you're going to
be investing in it again
skillshare is a great resource that you
can use to begin learning as well as
having
access to tons of other classes so be
sure to click the link in the
description below and be one of the
first 1000 people to claim your free
trial of the premium membership
but if you did enjoy this video do hit
the like button do subscribe those
things are free but they
really help out with the channel my
friends i wish you the best rest of the
day
i look forward to seeing you in the next
part of the series things are going to
be getting
really really interesting but as always
hand to head
too salute days is yet to come
[Music]
too many times has come to pass
[Music]
too many moments put aside